it's early morning at the headquarters
of Rwanda cycling team John dark jira
bunt 0 is warming up together were the
other cyclists they have three to four
hours of training ahead of them in
Rwanda Hills sean is the only woman in
team Rwanda and last year she was the
first black African woman ever to ride
at the UCI road world championships how
do court I can only tell other girls and
women love the sport and believe in your
potential I never thought that I would
cycle in the USA or Switzerland I heard
about those places but I didn't know
what it was like there I've been able to
travel and meet lots of people Jean is
ambitious she needs competition there
are no other women who were at her level
so the trainer lets her cycle would the
men certain fiki chiappa she just
suddenly turned up with a lot of talent
and she seriously want it to be a
cyclist really set a user and she's not
only a good cyclist with prospects bun
she encourages other women in Rwanda and
Africa to do sports to Malta thumb not a
lot easier Wanda me or see on FB a visit
to her home village a long way from the
training center bikes are ubiquitous
here too jean has just come from an
international competition in Morocco she
tells her mother that she has two days
before she gets back to training did a
Louisville number Queen it used to be
difficult for me to make ends meet I
also had to pay for her bus fares and
when the bicycle was broken I had to
help her with money to get it repaired
today jean has able to help her family
up with the money she earns from cycling
she gets almost 1,000 euros a year as a
member of the national team for John
there's nothing better than coming back
visit her family she comes to see them
every three months
if you don't keep it work well I'm
really happy to see my friends I really
miss them it's important for her to her
listen what I came back acquisition the
mentor you either the world 15 cm 2 CL
Sakuya jean has been cycling for Rwanda
national team in Africa for two years
now she wants to take part in races in
Europe she says there are more
competitions for women there and she
hopes that her biggest dream will come
true to cycle for Rwanda in the Olympics